once he leaves him now watch out here's
curry
[Music]
misses the three and beat again with a
put back offensive fouling
oh embiid gets into it collins gets in
his face
collins goes down to the ground embiid
is moving towards him but putting his
hands out wide
security steps in
be interesting to see what they call
here they called an offensive foul
initially on embiid
and then embiid something happened to
embiid when he was down on the floor
he reacted to collins and then he moved
in the collins after the whistle and
when they went out of bounds but kept
his arms out wide
now you judge for yourself this is
unfortunate for both teams
you're going to see it right now watch
here oh
offensive foul as he goes back in
into the defensive player i'll keep an
eye on it now
right watch what happens when the two
guys are on the floor here that's right
there goes there goes the shot that
that's what columns was upset about
embiid landed on top of him and now
now this is see this is unpowerful
you're just asking now
for bad news and the other thing too
hubia is does anybody come off either
bench
during an altercation anybody comes off
the
the bench onto the floor and it doesn't
look like anybody does in that situation
you see this this is this is unnecessary
you don't have to walk them down
i we can't hear what the verbal is going
on right now
in the face of both guys well colin
started it there with the push
yep no doubt about it and then embiid
retaliates
trey young steps in tries to help his
teammate
and then you see george hill
[Applause]
so they're trying to sort this out crew
chief scott foster pat freyr james